si seulement tu avais pu admirer le
spectacle le bateau volait dans le vent
et dans le ciel ils ont lancé une pluie
d'étoiles d'accord écoute-moi chez les
humains c'est la pagaille la vie sous la
mer c'est bien mieux que ceux qui nous
ont sur terre
le roseau est toujours plus vert dans le
Marais d'à côté toi tu aimerais bien
vivre sur Terre bonjour la calamité
regarde bien le monde qui t’entoure dans
l'océan parfumé on fait quand on avale
tous les jours mieux qu'une poule à pas
trouver sous l'océan
sous l'océan
c'est bien mieux tout le monde est
heureux sous l'océan là où il bosse
toute la journée
esclavagé épuisé pendant qu'on plonge
comme des infos je suis l'océan
[Musique]